good evening Netflix will spend a
billion dollars in Europe alone on new
content this year that's twice as much
as last year but only part of the eight
billion dollars it will spend in total
worldwide the challenge new online
services has already led to
consolidation not least AT&T trying to
buy Time Warner and of course interest
in Sky in Europe so what does the
streaming revolution mean for
traditional broadcasters and who are the
likely winners well joining me here is
the media and Technology analyst Claire
Enders and live from New York I'm joined
by Daniel Ives who's chief strategy
officer and head of technology research
at GBH insights so Daniel let me turn to
you first it seems now that Netflix is
more focused on international growth and
in the u.s. is that right yeah milk
International is really the fuel in the
engine at this point I mean we believe
international subs go from about 60
million today to upwards of a hundred
million and by 2020 so it's really an
international growth story for Netflix
and that's why that they are putting
significant dollars you know we'll call
it a billion they're spending this year
in a written content about 35% that's
original significant portion going
internationally right now they've kind
of circled Western Europe and especially
parts of Asia as areas are going to
significantly invest in over the coming
years they put on something like seven
and a half million subscribers in the
last quarter I mean to put that in
context Amazon Prime took a more than a
decade to get to 100 million who's got
the deeper pockets it along the term
look I mean if you look at it right here
I mean Netflix you know is gonna be
spending will called eight billion this
year next year could be spending ten to
eleven billion you know I think when it
comes to streaming I mean they have a
massive competitive mode you know right
now they're really the only game in town
I mean you could say who Amazon in the
video side much further down on second
and third it's really now about Disney
with the Fox acquisition obviously sky's
front and center with the Comcast you
know potential competitive bid but it's
really Disney in 2019 coming around the
corner
Netflix realizes there's a way
no opportunity here where they have to
significantly spend and put iron
fortress around not just domestically
but international as that's really gonna
be a key not just for them but for the
stock all right Claire Enders let me
bring you in here I mean who's most at
risk here is it the traditional
broadcasters the BBC's and buy TVs of
this world or is it other streaming
rivals well I mean the existing
broadcasters have faced in this country
Netflix for the last six years and
Netflix has taken about five percent of
the total audience over that time and by
spending a huge amount on originals and
a huge amount on acquisitions of Rights
Netflix has established a really strong
position in the UK it's one of its
leading foreign markets but inherently
this is a market where people spend a
great deal on content anyway so the
total expenditure on content in this
market already is 12 and a half billion
before you start to look at Netflix so a
billion dollars isn't going to go that
far another point of comparison Germany
has a market with total revenues of 21
billion pounds you know that's 30
billion dollars you know what is 500
million dollars in Germany going to buy
Netflix but what we've seen is a lot of
completely new and innovative
partnerships devote there's no doubt
that the linear broadcasters the public
service broadcasters like the BBC ard
sky all the institutions are getting
together and engaging in completely
innovative partnerships to try to have
the budgets to confront the Netflix sums
because really there are three times as
many original series on for consumers so
consumers have just never had it so good
and we are very used to competition in
the UK other markets perhaps less but
remember that Sky started in 1989
and we've had decades of competition
from a large number of sources including
from Netflix and Amazon and so on very
interesting clear though that 80% of
Netflix is audience is not watching
original content but reruns of old shows
like friends absolutely right so so they
put a lot of prominence on originals
here the crown has been a huge hit for
them in terms of driving subscribers but
your
right you know when you look at the
actual viewing insights that we get from
barbed you're looking at very very small
amounts of viewing for those originals
which if you compare it with the BBC or
ITV they would be expecting 5 million 6
million viewers if they spent as much as
Netflix on a series and so you know
we're looking at some very well-armed
competition in Europe and you know I
think what we're seeing is simply the
evolution towards a last higher cost
model for original material well Daniel
lives Netflix of course is still burning
cash lest we forget what happens when
investors start demanding return yeah me
look I mean good you your other guys had
great points and I think to this point I
mean Netflix right now from an
embassador perspective they're given
them flexibility I'd say really over the
next call it one to two years to spend
significant dollars in hopes of sort of
this growth engine not just on domestic
but also international I think patients
will wear thin if you don't start to see
a significant margin ramp over the next
two three years but at least for now
it's all about sub growth and it's all
about the international expansion look
at this past quarter it was basically in
line numbers in terms of revenue and EPS
they beat sub significantly and stock
makes an all-time high
so right now investors are leaves are
focus on sub growth and really focus on
international and right now that Disney
acquisition with Fox and Sky is probably
one of the biggest question marks in
terms of just how aggressive Disney gets
especially in the UK and internationally
all right Daniel lives in New York and
Claire and is here in London leave it
there I'm afraid thanks both for joining
me